ich weiß die sicherheit frieden freiheit
wohlstand deutschlands ist amerika
wichtig ich weiß auch für deutschland
ist amerika wie sie sind ein schicksal
als partnerschaft ich liebe dieses land
leben schon lange hier bin aber der
meinung deutschland tut zu wenig und
sich selbst zu schützen
um andere regierungen in der
nachbarschaft zu beeinflussen um die
globalisierung in seinem sinne zu
gestalten weil deutschland ist so groß
und so reicht und geostrategische so
wichtig es kann nicht auf einfluss
verzichten
die bundeswehr hat probleme das muss man
auch zugeben und wir haben uns sehr
verwundbar gemacht weil deutschland ist
umschlagplatz und alles und gehandelt
und man ist sehr verwundbar aber die
ukraine
können mit deutschen waffen
leben anderer ukraine retten